as lengthy as the runtime was for
Avengers infinity war there's still more
the movie we didn't see and directors
Joe and Anthony Russo have indicated
that fans can expect plenty of bonus
material to come and to take home copies
of the film although they've yet to
spell out exactly which deleted and
extended scenes could be included they
along with the film's cast have shared a
few hints about what might be missing
from the movie's theatrical version
here's a look at some of the Avengers
infinity war scenes that might make the
DVD extras and a few that may never see
the light of day
guardians get silly one missing scene
the Russo brothers have promised
involves the guardians of the galaxy
flexing their funny bones Anthony Russo
told Entertainment Weekly it's a scene
where they're sort of stuck there's a
point in the movie where they're stuck
without knowing what to do it was really
fun and it was very endearing to us but
because the movie is so big and so
propulsive it just wasn't quite pushing
us where we needed to go that
description indicates this is an
extension of the scene on nowhere when
Peter quill Drax and mantas are duped by
Thanos as reality stone trickery and
left to fester on the broken planet
Russo confirmed as much in a later
interview with comicbook.com saying it's
at that moment in the movie where they
have lost Gamora to Thanos and the know
where and they don't know what to do
about it
they don't know where to go they have no
idea what to do and it serves as this
very absurd scene about the Guardians
not knowing what to do that's very very
funny
in other words expect to see some more
humor from the star-lord that might help
make fans less mad at it Wow pepper and
company in the park in one of the
earliest scenes from infinity war Tony
Stark can be seen taking a walk with his
ladylove Pepper Potts as the to discuss
his dream about her being pregnant
before he runs off to deal with
Vanessa's looming threats that exchange
may have been a mere primer for what's
to come between the two in Avengers 4
but it was also an abbreviated version
of what was actually filmed screenplay
co-writer Christopher Markus told
GameSpot that there were a lot more
people who join the fray for that scene
saying we shot an unbelievably long
version of Tony and pepper in the park
that features cameos it was sort of
Robert and his friends day at the park
judging from behind-the-scenes footage
taken during the shoot
happy may be one of the
missing persons we can expect to see in
the fuller version go team yeah
Hulkbuster smash much has been made of
the fact that Bruce Banner was unable to
transform into the Hulk on cue in
Avengers infinity war but there may be
reason to believe that another version
of the film might have featured Hulk
going berserk in the Hulkbuster suit
while we know that the trailers big
tracking shot was made specifically to
mislead audiences about what was to come
on the banner Hulk front in the battle
of Wakanda there are other glimpses from
the trailer that seemed to indicate some
Hulk smashing as well for example
there's a moment in the first trailer
when Bruce is shown standing next to a
broken version of the Hulkbuster suit
looking a little embarrassed although
there's no official indication that a
Hulk in the Hulkbuster suit scene was
shot the fact that Funko pop released a
toy version of the Green Giant breaking
through the red getup has led some fans
to believe it points to yet another
scene that didn't make the final cut of
the film but might find its way into
your home copy now let's talk about a
few of those scenes that were thought up
but never produced a Civil War reunion
perhaps the most disappointing aspect of
Avengers infinity war is that it didn't
fully resolve the conflict between Iron
Man and Captain America sure there's a
date on between the two that comes up by
way of flip-phone but the two don't
share the screen even though they're
fighting for the same team again
according to co-writer Stephen McFeely
however at least one draft of the film
script would have brought them back
together at last
he told Yahoo movies our first sort of
wonky draft featured the idea that they
had to get back in the same room
together that meant you're slowing down
your Thanos stones plot to deal with
threads from other movies as much as we
wanted to do it and as many times as we
wrote those scenes it became clear that
this movie needed to be propulsive and
be about Thanos and what he represented
to the Avengers it's not over yet
however and Joe Russo has teased that
Captain America Civil War contains a big
hint about what's to come and Avengers 4
so now that Iron Man has been left alone
on Titan perhaps the next film will
finally bring their face-to-face scene
to fruition let's go the Power Stone
while Avengers infinity war showed how
Thanos acquired most of the Infinity
stones we didn't get to see him claim
the Power Stone which had previously
been left in the care of the No
koron Xander according to McFeely the
scene was originally written into the
film but had to be edited out of the
working script for the sake of
streamlining the story as he explained
to Yahoo movies I do remember there was
as and our draft and it just became
unwieldy it's lovely to go back to a
small part of guardians of the galaxy
and explore how you get that stone but
we had to eventually economize so
instead of seeing the mad Titan destroy
that planet we only get to hear about it
secondhand similarly fans also never get
to find out exactly how he snagged the
reality stone because the Guardians
don't arrive until after he's collected
the ether from the collector the next
chapter since adventures infinity war
and Avengers 4 are two parts of one
overarching narrative there was bound to
be at least a little confusion over
which scenes were filmed for which
movies and some of the cast's interviews
reflect as much or do they there have
been several instances of Avengers stars
discussing production on scenes we
haven't seen yet did you thrust your
hand towards someone wearing like a blue
suit with ping-pong balls glowed on Luna
yes then you still have powers one of
the biggest points of confusion seems to
center around whether a giant group
scene would be included in infinity war
or the next film one particular scene
there's like 32 of there's a lot there's
so many of us I don't even know who's a
Marvel character and he's like a crew
member Mark Ruffalo implied that he'd
worked with tilda swinton and Cate
Blanchett's which made folks believe the
ancient one the goddess of death would
make an appearance at some point and
Sebastian stand said it included
everyone from Nick Fury to Janet Van
Dyne even the Russos seem to be confused
about where it end up they agreed
there'd be a Civil War Airport sized
scene an infinity war with Joe Russo
saying we have like an equivalent that's
like you know if you had a comic book
and you open it up to your double panel
and then you fold it out and then you
folded it out again and again since
nothing like that came through an
infinity war we just have to believe
it's being reserved for round 4 instead
but we'll have to wait till next year to
find out for sure
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]